la caravana podrá volver a avanzar en
mexico y esta vez de forma regular
representantes de los migrantes y del
gobierno llegaron a un acuerdo para
regularizar a cerca de 500 personas
permitiendo el paso hacia el norte a
quienes quieran seguir su ruta
las autoridades se comprometen al
respeto y la promoción de los derechos
humanos de los migrantes miembros de la
caravana a efecto de que no sean
vulnerados los derechos emanados de la
constitución
la caravana formada por centroamericanos
y haitianos llegó a ciudad de méxico
esta semana han estado pidiendo un mejor
trato de las autoridades mexicanas como
residencias permanentes y vía libre para
ir hasta eeuu buscan una mejor vida
bueno seguir a esta edad pues lado
porque
creo que estaremos mejor a partir
de aquí bueno es cierto son más con
vuelos pero lo siento más peligroso esta
caravana a partir del 23 de octubre
desde tapachula estaba formada por miles
de emigrantes pero con el paso de los
días muchos obtuvieron visados
humanitarios sin embargo las nuevas
rutas tampoco garantizan el éxito para
los que quieren llegar a eeuu este mes
se reactivó el quédate en mexico el
programa que obliga a los solicitantes
de refugio a esperar su resolución al
otro lado de la frontera estadounidense
este año méxico ha interceptado más de
228 mil personas reportando a más de 82
mil es una cifra récord en 15 años que
se suma a máximos históricos de la
solicitud de refugios con más de 108 mil
peticiones